[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them dick Tator
Donnie
dictater tater tot I I don't
know I mean we knew we knew that he
wants to be a dictator right I just
isn't
[__] we know we know that they his
follower the magga cult wants him to be
a dictator that's not [__]
news of course the media is
[__] wowed by this like oh my God he
said it out loud like what come on now
of course he said it out loud he's gonna
say Dumber [__] than this it's Donald
Trump [__] sake of course of course he
wants to be a
dictator of course he does it's his only
option if you really do the math right
like is his only option for survival at
this
point I mean think about it think about
it think about it in this perspective he
doesn't think he can get away with this
he knows he can get away with saying
this he knows
it he knows that he can get away with
this because the magga cult wants an
authoritarian they want a
dictator they are
craving a dictator to oppress their
enemies whoever that their enemies
are that's what they want a lot of
people are asking what did he get away
with he said out loud last night on Sean
Hannity's
show that he will be a dictator day
one day one I'll be a dictator now the
way he said it and this is the important
part folks
because they want a dictator and he
knows that they want a dict that they
want him to be the
dictator
okay that's how Cults work that's how
they [__] work
they see the cult leader as their savior
as their
God they they want him to be a dictator
and he knows it so he can get away with
saying he'll be dictator on day one now
the way he said it he said it to where
it's only one day that he's GNA be a
dictator right it's only one day do you
remember in Jurassic Park when they're
all sitting around in the very beginning
around the table with the lawyer and the
lawyer and they're trying to figure out
how much they're going to charge for
people what we'll have a a coupon day or
something that's it they'll have a
coupon day so he's going to have a
dictator coupon day right the way he
said it is I'm only gonna be a dictator
on day one only on day one so we're
supposed to believe that we're going to
elect a dictator but only for one day
that coupon day it's a coupon dictator
they you know what I mean it's kind of
like
that he's gonna go much further than
this folks and the reason why he says it
this way though right now is because he
knows the cult wants him to be a
dictator but he also understands that
they have to be able to defend that he's
going to be a
dictator and there's a slow walk to
that okay it's a slow walk he
understands he has to start it I'm not
going to be a dictator to I'm only going
to be a dictator for one day and then
like well I mean as long as it takes
I'll be a dictator as long as it takes
that's the next
step because the cult has to defend this
against
us we the Democracy get to say so you're
going to vote for a guy who's going to
be a dictator are you saying you're
going to vote for a Hitler that's what
you're going to do and they get and
they're going to say no no no no no no
no no no no it's dictator coupon day
it's only one day I he's only going to
be dictator for one day that's it
they're already doing it on Fox News I'm
gonna show you a clip they're already
doing
this casting this off as oh this is just
this is just him talking about executive
orders right it's only for one day it's
just a dictator coupon
day folks let me let me tell you
something
Joe Biden I think yesterday said that
the only reason why he's running is
because Donald Trump's
running that tells you all you need to
know that tells
you all you need to know that Joe Biden
would not get in this
race if Donald Trump wasn't
running because Joe Biden knows knows
he's going to trounce
Trump because Joe Biden is like the the
the opposite of trump right he's the
Steady Hand steady wins the race
right America's gonna go well I can
either choose the old guy that doesn't
do crazy [__] or I can choose the guy
that wants to be a dictator on day
one that's that's gonna be the choice
and Donald Trump has already laid out
the choice for that that's why Joe
Biden's like I gotta run against him
because it's Trump if it was anyone else
I might let someone else take the Reigns
but I know I can beat Trump and Trump is
the biggest threat to
democracy that's the thought
process and really honestly folks if we
can't beat this [__] when he's saying
[__] out loud like yeah we're gonna have
a dictator coupon day day one I'm gonna
be the [__]
dictator and I'm gonna I'm going to
[__] use every single power that I
can to oppress people in this country
and my enemies are
first uh he wants to be dictator he
knows the cult wants him to be a
dictator so he's going to slow walk it
to where they're like yeah
I mean you're going to see Mega cult
members in your comments saying crazy
ass [__] like well Hitler wasn't that
bad if you really do the math like
they're gonna be saying [__] like that
here
soon white Christian nationalists are
gonna be on the well I mean was Hitler
all that bad I mean really was he was he
I mean he did some good stuff right
they're they're getting
there and he's gonna pull them
there alls we got to do is just keep
yelling and screaming and pointing at it
look look [__] they want a
dictator
now the thing that I think he's
overestimating here is how many people
want an
authoritarian he also said in this
interview last night with Sean Hannity
that he estimated he would get 150
million
votes let me say that again Donald Trump
thinks in
2024 he's going to
get50 million
votes all right let me let me let me
give you a little clue here on how many
votes there are to get in 2020 was the
highest turnout in our country's history
in our country's history it was the
highest turnout and we had a pandemic
the one reason why is because [__]
Trump 81 million people didn't vote for
Joe Biden they cast their ballot for Joe
Biden but a lot of that 81 million voted
against authoritarianism voted against
Trump because they saw that he was gonna
be a [__] dictator and he's a buffoon
they voted against him
81 million okay Joe Biden won by almost
8 million votes in that election so
Donald Trump got almost 73 million votes
now if you do a little math and figure
it out he thinks he's going to get all
the
votes he thinks he's gonna get all the
votes right now what he's really doing
is setting up to where when Joe Biden
beats him I think Joe Biden's gonna be
him by a margin of more than 10 million
this time yes uh mark it down December 6
Wednesday at
1211 p.m. uh 2023 Tony Michaels said
that Joe Biden will beat him by a margin
of more than 10
million 10 million that's going to be
the margin it'll be the biggest margin
in history and he'll break his
record of the biggest margin in history
that he had in 2020 that's
right it that is gonna happen
now what Donald Trump is doing is
setting up the fact that he's supposed
to get all the
votes all of them there's not supposed
to be anyone that's going to vote for
Biden right this is the other [__]
predetermined cognitive dissidence that
he is laying the ground workor for is
that obviously everyone in the country
wants a dictator I want to be
dictator and
and and they're all going to vote for me
to to be dictator on day one but it's a
coupon day only day one right now right
now again I would say probably we get
close to March where he's really secured
several primaries he will start to say
I'll be dictator as long as it takes
because they're going to ask him like so
you're claiming that you want to be
dictator only on one day explain how
that works and he's going to say well
you know I'll be dictator as long as it
takes as long as it takes
and that's what's going to
happen in other
news speaking of
uh Fallen Fallen buffoons Kevin McCarthy
is not going to seek re-election and
he's leaving his house
seat uh from Bakersville California at
the end of the year now if you know how
this
works Gavin Nome the governor of
California gets to appoint someone to
that seat of course Gavin Nome is going
to appoint a Democrat um that Democrat
probably will not win it will probably
be a republican that wins in Bakersfield
because Bakersfield is a [__]
dumpster
fire just the pure facts okay all right
just what it
is
but Kevin McCarthy is out now this
leaves them with about two I believe is
the margin of a razor thin major
now I've been um giving attention to
Andy
ogles that Phil Williams of nc5 in
Nashville Tennessee has been reporting
Andy will Andy oakal devolder um that's
what I call him Andy ogal devolder is
the George Santos of Tennessee of course
they're all George Santos all these
[__] Republicans are George
Santos
right so Andy ogles looks like could
catch some charges I mean the guy really
is
uh how shall I say it a [__] fraud
and it looks like it's criminal fraud to
me it seems like it it could be criminal
fraud to me so um Andy ogles looks like
he may be
out which leaves their majority down to
just one or two now this is important in
that Mike Johnson can't do
[__] without
Democrats now in January we're going to
have another government shutdown because
that was the plan the entire
time the plan the entire time was to
kick the CR into January so that MAA
wouldn't have to explain to their
relatives that have two brain cells to
rub together of why the Republicans
can't govern right so mikro Johnson the
wiener of the house kicked
the the CR can and the government
shutdown can into January now in January
their margin will be razor thin like one
or two votes depending on if someone
gets sick or if they're not in
Washington at the time I mean there's
over 400 members so it's not always a
case where every single member can be
there at the exact moment of a
vote sometimes that's difficult
depending on the member you know people
have doctor's appointments IES they have
families there's all kinds of stuff that
could
happen so we're on the verge of a
government shutdown in January now the
the media hasn't really picked up on
that narrative yet um they're still
talking about you
know why Kevin McCarthy is [__]
resigning well Kevin McCarthy is
resigning because that's what happens
when you remove a
speaker that's what [__] happens
you're gone you're done out see you
later [__] Hit the Road Jack
that's what [__] happens the only
reason why Kevin McCarthy has held on
this long in the first place is because
even Kevin McCarthy is the adult in the
room which is [__] laughable at
best but that's where we're at that's
where we're at with the Republican Party
they're [__] dead they don't have a
workable governing party I mean Jesus
Christ their their [__] savior their
mango musolini Jesus is on Fox news on
Sean Hannity Show saying he wants to be
a [__] dictator I've been telling you
and yelling and screaming all year the
reason why Republicans can't do [__] is
because their party is already under
authoritarian
rule we do not have two parties in this
country we do not we only have one party
that is interested in democracy only one
party that is interested in [__]
governing the other party is under
authoritarian
Rule and their dictator their their
white Republican Jesus their mango
musolini deity is Donald
Trump and he's saying it out
loud what do you want from
me I've been telling you this all God
damn
year all year I've been saying this
[__] all [__] year now there seems to
be some movement in the DC trial because
that oh man A lot of people are gonna
get all [__] crazy about
this the DC trial it appears that
there's some movement Jack Smith has um
released kind of the evidence that
they're going to use against Trump but
also it it feels like there's going to
be a superseding indictment and they're
going to re in bring in some other
people into this
indictment I I don't I don't know how
quickly that will happen or how that
will happen um I've kind of been
disappointed in Jack Smith if you want
to know the honest truth and the reason
why is because Jack Smith in his motions
it appears that he thinks he can save
the country his job is not to save the
country folks that's our [__] job our
job is to save the country his job is to
prosecute crimes and to prosecute crimes
that Trump committed on this [__]
country so
it appears If he if he actually goes
ahead with the prosecution properly and
does a superseding indictment and and
indicts co-conspirators on this case
which is what should happen I don't give
a [__] about speed I don't care about
when he's [__] convicted and all that
nonsense prosecute him properly and
prosecute his co-conspirators properly
stop trying to [__] do things in
order to exclude Trump from the [__]
Norm stop doing that if you keep [__]
bending the rules for him he's gonna
keep bending the rules for himself folks
that's how it's going to work it's dumb
stupid [__] liberals do it all the time
they keep doing it they keep yelling and
screaming about this 14th Amendment
thing that's supposed to go to the court
in Colorado it's going to get [__]
slammed dunk it's going to get thrown in
the trash and it's going to fact to the
Supreme Court where it's also going to
get thrown into trash and all of you out
there that have been telling me that I'm
[__] wrong are going to be wrong and
you're going to [__] stick your foot
in your mouth because alls you've done
is damag the institution of democracy
that's all you've done you haven't done
anything you won't 14 teeth him on a
ballot it's not gonna happen stop it
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
you're hurting democracy that's what
you're doing when you're doing this
stupid [__]
we can [__] beat
him um and Jinx says here that the
judges set the timetable yeah they do
set the timetable the problem is the
problem is is if the grand jury acts the
judge has to now act on that
timet
okay again people I'm just telling you
what the [__] the [__] reality is I'm
not trying to tell you what you want to
hear I'm not trying to do that if I was
trying to tell you what you want to hear
I would say [__] like yeah we need a
14th him and if we 14th him we'll keep
him off the B and democracy will be
saved and Jack Smith he's gonna work so
hard to make sure that Donald Trump is
brought to Justice Jack Jack Smith
doesn't get to control the [__] court
dates oh judge chuin is gonna make sure
to save democracy that's not how it
works I mean I would love to sit here
and bu [__] you and tell you the
[__] that you want to hear I really
would that would be [__] great
honestly someone might even pay me to do
that [__] there's a lot of [__]
commentators that get paid to do that
kind of [__] out there they do they get
paid to say the [__] you want to hear
[__] just go turn on MSNBC or CNN
there's plenty of people getting paid on
there telling you the [__] you want to
hear I that's not my job that's not how
I view it at least my job is not to tell
you what the [__] makes you feel good if
it's a bunch of
[__] I'm the actual liberal media
okay that's what this is that's what
this is here this is the actual liberal
media I look through the prism of
liberalism and democracy every [__]
day that's that's what I try to do
and I try to set the narrative in that
form and fashion so we can start at a
reasonable [__] position in our
democracy to defend
it a Jin is saying Tony I didn't say to
you I'm I'm not I'm not harping on you
jinx again I I I just I like your
comment so I wanted to bring it up a lot
a lot of people get that Twisted right
because I like the scent I like to
sending comments I know a lot of you are
chatting some of you being sarcastic
some of you aren't meaning exactly what
you're posting and some of you it's not
in full
context okay but that's okay that
doesn't matter that's why I welcome
desent here that's why I welcome it
that's why I want you to listen even if
you [__] hate my guts or you don't
like what I'm saying a lot of people
hated the Liz Cheney talk well she's
going to try to run for president and
I'm going to be correct and everyone who
loved Liz Cheney was [__] sucking on
the Liz Cheney tee is going to eat their
[__] words because I don't give a
[__] about the [__] lies and the
[__] I only care about the real
rawal truth that's all I give a [__]
about that's all I want I want to
[__] strip everything
down boil it down to just what matters
that's it
period and what matters to me and I
think what matters to most the audience
is is that our democracy survives and
that the foundation of our democracy
isn't cracked and and and and marred up
into a thousand pieces because these
fascists think that they get to have our
democracy and turn it into an
authoritarian
State and I think the truth will get us
there and as long as there's someone
like me yelling and screaming into a
microphone like I do every day with the
truth the real raw truth not the [__]
[__] stuff oh well there is the 14th
Amendment with section three Tony that's
a fact it exists Tony yeah but I mean
yeah but you're [__] absolutely
ignoring the fact that the courts aren't
going to do that and and if you have
enough cognitive dissidents to believe
that they're going to do that more power
to you keep [__] dreaming I guess I
don't know what to tell you like I I I
want him to be 14th I don't want him to
run I don't want him to be president I
want him out of our [__] lives I want
him to be shut the [__] up I want him
gone I don't like like this morning I
had to get up and watch all these stupid
[__] Trump clips and I'm gonna show
you today yes we're gonna watch Trump
talk today because it's really [__]
relevant it's really [__] relevant in
the fight for democracy these clips are
most Trump Clips are not relevant it's
just the same old stupid [__] he's
saying it's the same old [__] five
minutes 15 minute [__] standup
routine the shitty standup routine that
he's got that he does at his Nazi
rallies but this is
different there's movement in his speech
there's movement in his rhetoric and
it's important that you know
it it's important that you know
it and the reason why isn't because I
mean yeah it's kind of scary that we're
in a situation where a cult has formed
in this country that that that that
parades around as a political party and
they have decided that the cult leader
if they're okay with him being a
dictator that's kind of you know it's
kind of dangerous and scary the good
news is that they're saying the quiet
part out loud and they're giving us all
the [__] ammunition we need to
[__] beat
them and I'm going to show you that
ammunition today because it's their own
words that is going to to absolutely
obliterate them in this next
election they're down to two votes in
the house folks two [__] votes that's
their margin of
majority that's their margin of majority
and they did that to themselves they
elected a George Santos they got rid of
Kevin McCarthy
okay Jesus Christ that the acting
speaker The Elf on the Shelf Patrick
McHenry he's not going to rerun kin
buuck not rerun there's going to be a
ton of them not going to rerun now some
people are going to say well that's
going to make it more that's going to
make the Republic and caucus more
radical more extreme they're already
extreme folks why do you think McKenry
McCarthy and buck are leaving they're
not leaving because the party needs to
be less extreme they're leaving because
they can't be part of that party anymore
they're forced
out
so all we got to do is keep our eye on
the
prize our eye on the
prize is the battle at The Ballot Box in
2024 and we will [__] win I promise
you this I know I know it's a big
promise but folks it's just math and
numbers that's why Joe Biden saying the
only reason why I'm running is because
that [__] buffoon is running and the
reason why is because it's math it's
math Joe Biden beat Donald Trump in 2020
the math is still there it still works
he will beat him again in 2024
period period and he'll beat him by a
bigger margin this time because Donald
Trump is not only driving away votes but
people are going to sit at home that's
right folks people are going to sit at
home but you shouldn't you should get
off your [__] ass and go engage in
democracy after the show after the show
after the show because we we do this
show every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central n Pacific
for two full hours you are here I am
here every single day this microphone is
powered by you the audience I could not
keep this microphone on without you it
is powered by you against fascism one
way you can do that is go to the merch
store go to the Tony michaels.com grab
your tattoo merch today guess what I got
a promo code for you till Sunday 10% off
your entire order at the Tony
michaels.com just go to the Tony
michaels.com scroll down to the tattoo
merch collection you can get hoodies
t-shirts uh crop hoodies coasters coffee
mugs metal prints
there's all cor kinds of great stuff in
there with the tattoo design on it go to
the Tony michaels.com go span down hit
the tattoo merch collection you get 10%
off your entire order here's the promo
code holiday 10 that's holiday 10
holiday 10 Z all caps holiday one0 is
the promo code for 10% off your entire
order if you order by Sunday if you
order by Sunday your order should be
here by Christmas that's right if you
order by Sunday with that promo code 10%
off your entire order holiday one Z
holiday 10 all
caps then your order should be received
by Christmas if you want to give it as a
Christmas gift or if it's just a great
Christmas gift to yourself because treat
yourself why not why not everyone stick
around we'll be back I'm going to show
you these clips I know I I don't I
didn't I didn't exactly want to watch
them myself this morning but I had to
because they're totally relevant in
today's news and we're going to talk
more about Kevin McCarthy and a few
other things don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim gems and
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again yours Bob dear Bob I'm fixing
to send you some more of them Doritos
you like the red bag not the live loving
blue one in your absence I discovered a
rash on my neck and no it ain't no
hickey and I even seen my cousin Brody
in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] them
[__] them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the
show that's
right old Donnie Big Mac wants to be a
dictator and the former Speaker of the
House Kevin McCarthy is out get out of
here [__] you're out [__] see
you later Hit the Road
Jack and all he did was keep the
government open got a few Democrats to
vote for him you think you think they
would go ahead and Al smike Johnson then
because he did the exact same thing uh
oh uh oh yeah the wiener of the house
Michael Johnson did the exact same thing
Kevin McCarthy got kicked out for now
I'm GNA go to these tapes of tapes Jesus
Christ what is this the [__]
1900s I I'm getting my cough is getting
better it really
is it's getting better I promise um but
when I laugh it it invokes a cough so
you know what am I supposed to do and I
know how you guys like when I get
cracked up but we're gonna have to try
to refrain for a few more days so I
don't have a coughing fit go on um
in the show now let's get to some of
these clips here is the clip where he
talks about how he's going to be day one
dictator here it is listen to
this love this guy he says you're not
gonna be a dictator are you I said no no
no other than day one listen to it again
he says you're not gonna be a dictator
are you I said no no no other than day
one we love this guy he says you're not
gonna be a dictator are you I said no no
no other than day one
it's so
funny it's so funny it's so funny now
this is the thing they do right it's
like oh it's a joke I wasn't
serious and they say don't take him
literally just take him seriously don't
take him seriously take him literally
listen to it again though what I mean
what do the [__] you want me to do what
do you want me to do we love this guy he
says you're not going to be a dictator
are you I said no no no other than day
one okay okay so he's saying the quiet
part out lot of he wants to be a
dictator everyone [__] knows this
[__] right everyone knows he wants to be
a [__]
dictator he hasn't been hiding that they
haven't been hiding that his cult hasn't
been hiding that they want him to be a
dictator they haven't hid that fact
right now um the one that is a little
more Sinister though uh is this video
here now the reason why it's a little
more Sinister is because Shan Hannity
really kind of ask him the question and
serves him up a softball here okay Shan
Hannity yeah I know the the clips
volumes are low but I'm trying to get
the volume up but it just it is what it
is let me see if I
can let me see if I can crank it up a
bit but here's the one here's the one
where Sean hanity serves him the
softball question for him to say oh no
no no no no no no I'm not going to do
that I wouldn't do that watch what he
does though watch this you would never
abuse power as retribution against
anybody except for day one except he's
going crazy except for day one meing
except for day
one it's a [__] coupon day they well
we'll have a a coupon day or that's
right yeah we'll have a coupon day it'll
be dictator coupon day it'll just be one
[__] day right one [__] day now
why is he saying this stuff again folks
the reason why he saying this [__]
listen to it one more time listen to it
you would never abuse power as
retribution against anybody except for
day one Okay the reason why he's saying
it like this is because he knows the
cult wants him to be the dictator um
someone here is saying The Purge
yeah seen the movie The Purge yeah yep
but here here's here's what he's telling
his cult you got to remember a l a lot
of people get this confused
everyone thinks Trump is talking to us
he's not talking to us [__]
he's not talking to us he's talking to
his sheep this is sheep
food this is [__] sheep food folks
that's what this is he's feeding the
[__]
sheep all right now this is the same
thing and he goes over this in this
interview and I'll play the clip where
he calls Joe Biden
Obama and the media a lot of dumb people
out there on the left and you know it's
a lot of people I know and it's [__]
ridiculous I can't even believe that
they played into this stupid thing but
they play into his hands every time when
he calls Biden Obama he's not he does
not think that Biden is not the
president and Obama is the president
he's speaking qanon dummy he's speaking
qanon it's not his dementia it's not his
mind going south
it's not that he doesn't know who the
president is he's speaking
qanon okay he's feeding the
Sheep is what he's doing and until we
get with the
truth I and I said this a long time ago
when he first started calling Biden
Obama you remember it I said it here on
the show he's he doesn't think that
Obama's
president it's [__] qanon talk it's
he's speaking qanon and feeding the
Sheep that's what he's doing but that's
what he's doing with this that's what
he's doing with this listen you would
never abuse power as retribution against
anybody except for day one the reason
why he's saying except for day one is
because the sheep have to defend the
position that he's taken against our
logic because rational thought would
tell you that if someone thinks that
they can be the dictator on just day one
that they'll stop being dictator once
the the [__] clock strikes
midnight right it's like the Cinderella
uh a spell that the Fairy Godmother cast
on Cinderella when the clock strikes
midnight that spell is over that's what
that's what they're GNA try to convince
us of he convinces the sheep and feeds
them the food hey you want to be a
dictator yeah I'll be a dictator but
just for one day
that way when they challenge you you can
just say it's just for one day no biggie
no biggie it's a [__] coupon day
dictator coupon day right it's what it
is because they have to defended against
you and your rational
thought so here's what's going to happen
literally you're going to make the
argument either in a [__] social
media post or in real life with your
Farm Fresh fash Uncle f Facebook Fred
right that hey man he wants to be a
dictator he said it he wants to be a
dictator on day one they're like no no
no no no that's not what he said what he
said was was he only want be a dictator
I mean dictator on the first day after
that he won't be a dictator I mean a
dictator anymore okay it's like a
dictator coupon day see we got to have a
coupon day for dictators that's what we
have here in this country cuz we're
Patriots we're Patriots we believe in
the American Constitution except on the
first day that our dictator is the
dictator okay that's how it works that's
the [__] they're gonna [__] they're
gonna feed back to
you that's how it's gonna work oh you
guys like the dict taster stuff maybe I
should have put that on the [__]
the thumbnail day one dick
taster I don't know [__] Dude Looks
Like a dick taster doesn't he I mean he
eats a lot of food I don't know hey I'm
not I'm not knocking it a lot of people
like the taste a dick it appears I don't
know I've watched porn I've been the
PornHub it looks like a lot of folks
like the taste of taste of Dick this guy
looks like one of them I don't know
maybe maybe not I don't know to each its
own though you know what I mean now
they're already they're already saying
this [__] on Fox News they're all
because here's what happens he sets the
tone and then Fox News and the right me
media gives them the way to argue the
stupid [__] back right you see what I
mean they they're like oh yeah he wants
to be dictator oh no how am I going to
combat that I'll go watch Fox News and
Fox News will tell me how to [__]
puke up [__] out of my mouth when
someone uses r Ral thought on me and
critical thinking skills when someone
uses their critical thinking skills on
me I'll just puke up what Fox News say
well here you go listen to it the Border
listen to
this the media has been focused on this
and attacking you yeah under no
circumstances you are promising America
tonight you would never abuse power as
retribution against anybody except for
day one except he's going crazy except
for day one meaning I want to close the
border and I want to drill he says
you're not going to be a dictator are
you I said no no no other than day one
we're closing the border and we're
drilling drilling drilling after that
I'm not a dictor senator he made light
of it is that what you want border
closed do you see him laughing watch
this watch this [__] watch this
[__] watch watch
Senator you
want Senator he made light of that is
that what you want and she's like you
want the Border closed because that
that's what they're doing they're like
oh my God he said that [__] whoa holy
[__] he said the quiet part out loud
what are you doing what the [__] you
doing T saying you want to be a dict
taster he wants to be a dict
dictator I mean you know
whatever but they're going to laugh it
off right oh it's
just he's just being funny he's just
being funny and he's just talking about
the Border because he says listen to the
clip because they played the part of the
clip here is this part of the clip
listen you would never abuse power as
retribution against anybody except for
day one except did you hear the crowd
yeah yeah the [__] dick Tas Her Lover
In The Crowd yeah he loves to taste a
dick woo woo let's taste that dick all
night long on the first day only on the
first day though except for day one
meaning I want to close the border and I
want to drill he say I want to close the
border and I want to
drill sounds like he wants to
taste the dick to me I don't know you're
not going to be a dictator are you I
said no no no other than day one we're
closing the border and we're drilling
drilling drilling after that I'm not a
dictator after that I'm not a
dictator after that I'm not a dictator
what is he talking about is he saying
that it takes a dictator to close the
border and to drill so they're only
going to drill for oral on one day and
they're only going to close the border
for one
day this is your emergency broadcast
system announcing the comc of the annual
Purge at theen all emergency services
will be
suspended it's like The
Purge because he's not gonna close the
border for just one day [__]
he's not gonna drill oil everywhere for
just one day and then he'll stop being
dictator this is the slow walk in the
narrative this is the slow walk to get
the
cult to want and to start screaming we
want him to be the dictator we want him
to be the dict taster dict taster dick
taster dick taster dick taster dick
taster dick taster you know it's the
crowd roaring and getting
uproar that's the point of all this but
they're gonna laugh it off right they're
GNA laugh it off like this [__]
chucklehead
does Senator he made light of it is that
what you want border
closed for sure and and not only does he
say he's going to do it we know he will
do it because he has done it and many of
the things that need to be done he can
do by executive order because they've
been undone by executive order that's
exactly see there you go executive order
no he they talking about executive order
he talking about executive or he's not
saying he won't be a dictator don't
believe him when he says what he says
just understand he's an idiot and he's
saying something completely different
this is all [__]
stupid this is [__]
dumb yes he wants to be a dictator
listen to what their [__] they're saying
when they're saying it and he's talking
about project 2025 as what he's really
talking about now let me show you this
yesterday we watched this video but this
video [__] says it all every single
last piece of this says it all and this
is Steve Bannon and cash
Patel yesterday listen highly confident
that when you go back and and is a
senior member of this uh uh
Administration president Trump's
Administration starting in the afternoon
of the 20th of January of 2025 uh do you
feel conf confident that you will be
able to deliver deliver the goods that
we can have serious prosecutions and
accountability and I want the morning
Joe producers that watch us and all the
producers that watch us this is just not
rhetoric we're absolutely dead serious
we're not you you cannot have a
constitutional republic and allow what
these uh deep Staters have done to the
country the Deep State the
administrative State the fourth branch
of government never mentioned in the
constitution is going to be taken apart
Brick by Brick okay first off a lot of
this [__] is just illegal that they
describe in this video it's
unconstitutional it's illegal they can't
just undo and tear apart the
administrative State like there's
[__] contracts and rules and law that
stand in their way right so remember
that remember when we're talking about
project
2025 they want a fascist State and
that's what Steve Bannon and cash Patel
are drooling over and wetting their
pants here and jerking off to they're
jerking off to project 2025 and they're
going to get there folks a lot of people
think I'm crazy when I say Republicans
are going to run on 2025 Bannon cash
Patel and Trump are gonna make them run
on 2025 that's right Republicans are
gonna be trying to tell you why having a
fascist State like project 20225 is a
good thing I'm not [__] you they're
going to use it as their platform form
to
run they're going to do that
now the reason why Donald Trump says day
one is because that's what they're going
to start saying is Project
2025 day one okay this is going I'm I'm
just telling you what the [__] is gonna
happen I'm already seeing it to
formulate and I've been talking about it
for months listen they're going to run
on project 2025 and they're going to say
when we're like project 2025 is is the
Republicans wanting a fascist state
they're gonna comment to you in social
media and say yeah project 2025 day one
that's what that's they're gonna say
that
[__] project 2025 day one that's what
they're gonna be saying soon it's gonna
happen it's going to be very soon that
they're going to say this
[__]
listen and the people people that did
these evil deeds will be held
accountable and prosecuted criminal
prosecutions uh cash I I know you're
probably going to be head of the CIA but
do you believe that you can deliver the
goods on this in pretty short in a
pretty short order of the first couple
of months so we can get okay first
off these two chuckleheads don't even
know what the director of the CIA does
if they think the director of the
CIA takes apart the bureaucracy
bureaucracy Brick by brick the director
of the CIA is in in in charge of
intelligence and it's not in charge of
domestic intelligence that's the
FBI these people are [__] they're and
again Steve Bannon and cash Patel know
this but they know the Sheep don't know
this again more sheep food it's more
sheep food uh Tracy says they're
delusional they're not delusional Their
audience is delusional that's what I'm
trying to say
is that Their audience is delusional
that again this is all a form and
fashion to get the cult to want Trump as
the dictator because he's gonna have to
run that
way he has to run to be the dictator
it's his only
choice it's his only choice it's his
only option they painted themselves into
the authoritarian Corner because he's
already the dictator and the
authoritarian of the Republican Party he
doesn't have a choice but run that way
so the the people who who propagate like
Trump Steve Bannon and cash Patel they
have to delude the Sheep so they're
delusional Tracy I I hope that you're
talking about Their audience because
their audience surely is delusional
Steve B and Cashel are not they are
[__] orchestrating the the op of a
misinformation campaign to get the cult
to be in a position to want a dict Ator
you are going to have manga family
members that you think were good people
at one point that were smart people that
would never [__] want a Hitler into
power and they're going to start saying
crazy [__] like well maybe Hitler wasn't
all that
bad I'm telling you it's gonna happen
get rolling on
prosecutions yes we got the bench for
banon and you know those guys I'm not
going to go out there and say their
names right now so Radical leftwing
Media can terrorize them but excuse me
the one thing we learned in the Trump
Administration the first go round is we
got to put in all America Patriots top
to bottom and we got them for law
enforcement we got them for Intel
collection we got them for offensive
operations we got them for DOD CIA
everywhere and the one thing we will do
that they never will do is we will
follow the facts and the law and go to
courts of Law and correct these justices
and lawyers who have been Prosecuting
these cases based on politics and
actually issuing them as lawfare we will
go out and find the conspirators not
just in government but in the media yes
we're g to come after the people in the
media who lied about American citizens
who helped Joe Biden rake presidential
elections we're going to come after you
whether it's criminally or civil we'll
figure that out but yeah we're putting
you all on notice and Steve this is why
they hate us this so they're threatening
me they're threatening me and people
like
me because I am the liberal media I
don't give a [__] what anyone says I am
the liberal media I am I'm the [__]
bar I'm the [__]
standard people don't know it yet but I
am because no one does what the [__] I
do there's people who do [__] that's
similar to me but they don't do [__]
that I do they don't say the [__] that I
say they don't say how I say it they
don't have the the actual narrative that
I have they just don't people are moving
in that direction and I hope more and
more copy me and I hope more and more
move in my direction because the more
that move in my direction the better off
we are from [__] pieces of fascist
trash like cash Patel
because he's not only is he threatening
lawyers and judges at this point he's
threatening people who who tell the
truth and who want the truth to be
known that's what he's doing he's
threatening them and he's threatening
them with weaponization of government
which is [__] Rich isn't it but this
they're describing project 2025 to their
sheep for a reason okay because they
have to slow walk these people into
believing this [__] is good because on
its face this [__] is trash it's fascist
trash on its face so they gota they
gotta [__] put chocolate syrup on it
right I mean think about if you had to
[__] feed someone a dog turd right
let's say your main goal in life and
someone would shoot and kill you if you
didn't get this person to eat this piece
of dog [__] right and they're like well
you can get them to eat the piece of dog
[__] however you want right however you
want them to get them to eat this piece
of fresh you know juicy warm piece of
dog [__] you just do it however you want
well what would be your first thought
you're like well you know what I do is
just put a bunch of [__] on it so that
you wouldn't really taste the dog [__]
that's what they're
doing that's what they're doing sheep
food they're feeding sheep the dog
[__] what do you want from me I mean if
you want to put it in less disgusting
way it's like when you got to feed your
dog a pill and you put it in a piece of
cheese right you trick that some [__]
you wrap it up in a piece of cheese and
you're like here here you go you want a
piece of cheese and they like yeah I
want a piece of cheese they like ah what
the [__] you put in that thing but they
eat it anyways same
thing same
thing same thing
right Yogi said that's nasty it is nasty
they're nasty [__] what what do
you want from me they're nasty
[__] they're trying
to you're telling me that these two some
[__] here aren't nasty Sun [__]
look at these two nasty
[__] I mean I I'm just showing
you the what the [__] they plan is again
the media gets all [__] distracted
and [__] they get all distracted right
oh [__] they're going to talk about how
Joe Biden isn't going to run and Trump
ain't going to run for the next three
weeks and how that's bad for Joe Biden
and it's good for Dean Phillips whoever
the [__] that
is come
on come on Joe Biden's just telling you
what the truth is is that yeah I'm
running against Trump because Trump's a
huge threat and I can whip his ass and
I'm gonna stay in the fight for the
American people because I believe in
democracy and I want my legacy to be
that I fought for democracy isn't that
what you want your legacy to be that's
what I want my legacy to be that's why I
sit here every
day that a lot of people are going to
say a lot of [__] about me a lot of [__]
they're gonna say a lot of
stuff they're gonna talk about my past
they're gonna talk about my my [__]
record they're going to talk about where
I was when I was how I was if I was in
prison why I was in they're gonna say a
lot of that [__] I don't give a [__] I
could care less what the [__] people say
about me on the Internet or in real life
I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] I'm not here
for that [__] I'm not here for
me I'm here to make
sure that I do something and I've got a
certain Talent I've got a certain talent
to talk into a microphone for an
extended period of time and I could do
it day after day after day after day
after day and I will never [__] stop
and these [__] chuckleheads will not
stop me they will have to come get me
and hang me by my [__] neck before I
shut the [__]
up no [__] way no [__]
how and they're threatening me with and
and other people like me with criminal
prosecution get the [__] out of here get
the [__] out of here with this
[__] what do I say on this show what
do I say stop concentrating on the
criminal trial stop concentrating on the
[__] if he's gonna go to prison
[__] I'm not hyperfocused on Trump going
to
prison I'm hyperfocused on you being his
[__]
jury you saving our democracy you the
people that's my belief that's what I
want my [__] Legacy to be I want
people to look back and go you know that
guy said a lot of FWS he said a a lot of
[__]
f-words he cussed a lot he said some
crazy [__] he had a crazy [__] show
they laughed on there they did some
serious [__] Goofs I mean it was
nuts but there was something about it
there's something about it that
captured the pro-democracy Coalition
there was something about it that had
this cathartic release there was
something about it that that stirred
this strategic
outrage for people to defend liberal
Democracy in America that's what I want
my legacy to be I don't want it to be
well he he had a lot of good commercials
on his show and he he he sold he sold
athletic greens and all kinds of
property and Scotland and he sold gold
and he hawked this and he hawked that oh
man he had a lot of he a lot of great
things that he sold a lot of great ad
reads I don't give a [__] about that man
what do I give a [__] about
that I mean yeah I got to keep the
microphone powered on but that that's
what you guys do you guys keep this P
microphone powered on against
fascism and that's going to be your
legacy that's going to be your
legacy that you didn't quit that you
fought just like this last election in
Ohio this last election in Virginia and
Kentucky that's their legacy
folks those things [__]
matter those things [__]
matter doing ad reads so that you can
make money for your show I mean yeah
that keeps you going that keeps you
talking and it's great to have piles of
money in your pocket but is it the thing
that matters [__]
no [__]
no we have have to let people know that
this is Project 2025 that they're
[__] talking
about and we have to let people know
that Trump is talking about day one and
he's talking about project
2025 that's what the [__] they're
talking
about I mean [__] we just saw uh Tommy
tuberville's blockade in the
Senate which is a precursor to project
2025 here's here's the of him being
chased in the parking lot being
questioned listen to this that you
didn't achieve exactly what you set out
to do that the policy still in place
yeah yeah I it was pretty much a draw I
mean they didn't get what they wanted we
didn't get what we wanted it it was
pretty much a draw so uh I'm I'm a
[__] idiot it was all a waste of time
it was all waste of time in the American
people's tax
dollars wh what a [__] joke what a
[__] joke keep going you joke and you
know the when they when you change the
rules it's hard to it's hard to win and
so they Chang the N NDA rules we didn't
get to fight for it to leave it in the
Senate and so did you hear that did you
hear
that they didn't win he didn't want the
military to get promotions he didn't
want the military to be strong that was
his
goal their goal with project 2025 is to
weaken our bureaucracy is to weaken our
military weaken our
defenses it's to weaken our democracy
folks that is their [__]
goal that's their
definition of
winning that's their
definition and they're G to say it
they're going to say project 2025 day
one this guy he says you're not going to
be a dictator are you I said no no no
other than day one we love this guy he
says you're not GNA be a dictator are
you I said no no no other than day
one you're G to see it project 2025 day
one they're going to start hashtagging
it they're going to start tweeting it
they're going to start saying it in
comments it's going to happen now I'm at
the top of the hour here and um I've got
some more Clips I want to show you I've
got one from Jasmine Crockett holy
[__] I'm in love with her Jasmine
Crockett is one of the best [__]
Congress people that we have in in the
new brand of liberalism that's right I
said the new brand of liberalism the new
brand of liberalism is not the Bernie
Bros or AOC it is Jasmine Crockett folks
holy holy
[__] holy [__] it is John vetman folks
that is the new brand of liberalism that
is the new brand of democrat in this
country and I got a clip of that to show
you and I've got more clips of this
Trump town hall to show
you um I also want to show you a video
from the
Missouri uh legislator where they're
trying to criminalize the the Missouri's
Nazi party is trying to CL criminalize
women's healthare I've got that to show
you as well and a few other Clips so
don't go anywhere don't go anywhere I'm
gonna take a quick drink break and catch
myself here stick around we'll be right
back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist
tyranny we know what you would do you'd
reach out and give that true American a
hand now here's your chance for only $50
a day you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those Trump
supporters and this is that moment send
your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another
moment [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] them we're back to the
Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the
show you know we're in the fight against
fascism me you the entire audience
entire Pro democracy Coalition and you
are the one that keeps this microphone
powered on against Fascism and I
appreciate every single one of you every
single day who comes here to support the
show rather you're watching you're
listening on Twitch or on YouTube or try
to on Facebook but I'm banned from
Facebook still I don't know if you go to
the Discord and you're chatting on
Discord but I I want I want to give you
an idea if if you have linked your
Twitch account to your Amazon account it
is one way this is really cool this is
one way if you have a Prime account that
you can support this show and this
microphone staying on uh powered against
fascism it is one way that you can do it
for free that's right it doesn't cost
you any any extra money if you have a
prime Amazon Prime account you just link
it to your Twitch
account and when you link your Amazon
account to your Twitch
account you get one free subscription to
Twitch and if you give that one free
subscription to dton Michaels podcast I
get a couple dollars but you have to
renew it every month let me show you how
it's done you go down to memberships you
click on this link right here it says
link Amazon and twitch it gives you the
directions on how to link them and also
how to resubscribe just click this link
right here it'll show you how to do it
so if you're out there and you have done
this before you have linked your Amazon
Prime account to the Twitch account make
sure you go resubscribe the directions
are right here at this link and that
helps us stay power on and it didn't
cost you a single extra dime really cool
way to support the show and it if you're
an Amazon Prime subscriber it doesn't
cost you a single extra nickel the other
thing I want to remind you of is there's
a promo code that's right a promo code
for 10% off off your entire order in the
tattoo merch collection store if you
want to go get your tattoo merch
collection it's the microphone that says
this machine kills fascist the Tony
Michaels podcast tattoo merch collection
design you go to the Tony michaels.com
you click on the tattoo merch collection
and use the promo code holiday1 that's
holiday 10 all caps holiday 10 for 10%
off your holiday order that's going till
Sunday and if you order by Sunday you
should get your order by Christmas if
you want to get it by Christmas so
there's my
grift to keep you know the microphone on
the other thing it's really cool that's
going on in the [__] fam universe is
the book club over on Discord that's
right the library of democracy is
promoting and and uh sponsoring the book
club over there they have it every
single week it's win every argument with
many Assan is the next book They're
they're reading so check out the book
club over on Discord again you can find
it at the Tony michaels.com you just pan
on down two memberships and you hit the
book club membership you will have to
join the Discord uh to to participate in
the book club but it's really fun the
everyone loves the book club and they're
going to be reading more and more books
in Janu actually in February I think
we're going to do Rachel boffers book
hit them where it hurts um and she'll
actually be participating in that book
club so get in the book club now get in
the groove that way in February you guys
can participate with Dr Rachel boffer in
a book club with her book with her book
also if
you excuse me if you want to support the
show monetarily you can go to live yeah
thanks you can go to live show support
on the Tony michaels.com you can buy me
a shoty jagger today is karaoke day it's
Wednesday I probably won't be singing
much maybe a little maybe low songs like
um like your your man have you heard
Your Man by Josh Turner baby lock the
door and turn the lights down low put
some music on that's solved and man my
voice is it's
hardd maybe maybe I'll get to sing
tonight for karaoke depends on how many
shots that you buy and how much Jagger
soes my throat uh so if you want to
support the show that way I appreciate
it I don't like dead air on the show so
I hate muting my mic for a cough I
really do I really do um so I'm gonna
I'm gonna go back here to some clips now
I want to show you because speaking of
Nazis you know we were talking about
Nazis as we always are because the
Republican party is just full of Nazis
but the best best part about Nazis is to
watch Nazis whine and cry what is better
than to bathe in Nazi and MAA tear right
am I right am I right is that not your
favorite pastime is to just swim in a
river and a sea of maanga and Nazi tears
and boy do I have some Maga Nazi tears
for you from this buffoon Nick Fuentes
the America first Nazi himself
apparently they have run out of money
and and they have run out of time and
they cannot do aack the America First
Nazi rally that they want to hold listen
to this this is [__] fantastic great
tears listen to the tears earlier in the
year we put out a trailer about aack
4 and it said December
2023 and initially we had planned on
doing aack 4 in December 2023
uh but obviously there hasn't been any
news about that we haven't given any
updates we haven't sold tickets or
anything like that uh and that's because
unfortunately we're going to postpone
afpac 4 it'll be happening in 2024
instead of this month we're looking for
a place to do aack 4 but we just haven't
quite found the right opportunity um and
we continue to struggle with things like
Banking and payment processes saying we
couldn't even sell tickets right now if
we wanted to because right now we're
between Banks and payment processors I
wonder why that is I wonder of it's
because I don't know he's an anti-semite
and Banks don't want to do business with
anti-semites and he's a
Nazi Banks don't want to do business
with I don't
know
Nazis could it be that could it be that
um so
unfortunately I do apologize we're going
to be it is going to happen but we are
going to have to postpone it until next
year just because again lot of extenda
circumstances when I said on Elijah sha
for show and they said have you ever
been in a romantic relationship have you
ever had sex with a girl and I said
no
uhoh apparently rat and the laboratory
have found audio from Nick Fuentes
apparently oh I don't know I just had to
show you those those Nazi
tears I always enjoy Nazi tears um you
know micro
Johnson damn it I was trying not to have
a coughing fit I promise I was trying
not to but it happened I think it was
all the laughing maybe that's what it
was anyways Mike cro Johnson yesterday
uh said this now I I am um this is
another laughable matter if you remember
he said this yesterday listen real quick
trust the American people to draw their
own conclusions we should not they
should not be dictated by some narrative
and accept that as fact so they can
review the tapes themselves we're going
through a methodical process of
releasing them as quickly as we can as
you know we have to blur some of the
faces of persons who uh participate in
in in the events of that day because we
don't want them to be retaliated against
and uh and and we don't want them to be
retaliated against with like I don't
know you know lawful prosecutions for
their crimes um
circuit circuit boy scout says as a gay
man I can say he is so gay I don't know
if you mean Nick quentes or micro
Johnson or both I don't know I don't
know who you're talking about maybe
you're talking about me I don't I don't
know I don't know who you're talking
about circuit boy Scout but I'm assuming
you're talking about Nick quentes or or
this guy micro Johnson because yeah to
me to me they both seem like they
totally could be I don't know why they
they stay closeted come out of the
closet guys come out of the closet we
welcome you in society but here
yesterday Michael Johnson had to take a
walk back he had to say no no no no no
we're not going to actually blur the
faces and the reason why is because
people are like aren't isn't this
obstruction and they like no it's not
obstruction because the doj already has
the tapes and then he was stuck in a
situation where he was saying well then
why are you blurring the faces for the
American people and the reason why is
because the internet slutes and the
Sedition Hunters out there would help
the FBI and law enforcement get these
people uh by doing their little their
little thing on the interwebs their
little interwebs thing and making sure
that they report who these people are
right using social media as the power of
the people people and the
crowdsource making sure that these
people get held accountable so micel
Johnson is going to blur the
insurrectionist his faces so that way
they couldn't be held accountable but
when he was caught when he was caught
saying well isn't this obstruction and
they're like no it's not obstruction
because the goj already has the tapes
then they were like then why the [__] do
you care oh that's right it's all
[__] oh you're lying huh you're
lying well here's the thing
I want to point out because a lot of
people are going to wonder how they're
going to spend this [__] because they're
going to have to spend this [__] folks
because more and more of these
insurrections are being caught from
these tapes and more of them are being
outed and more of them are being
arrested by the FBI in
charged uh with crimes of on the day of
January 6 now here's my favorite guy DC
Dano flush him down the [__] toy I
don't know why he calls himself Dro
doesn't he know that Dro gets flushed
down the [__] sewer system like it
Dro is designed to go to the sewer and
that's what it's designed to do but you
know what whatever I'm not
gonna it goes to the swamp dude Drano
ends up in the swamp every time okay
well but
whatever so this guy says speaker
Johnson says they will be blurring
people's faces as they released January
6 tape to protect them from the doj now
they're caught in they're paint
themselves into the stupid [__]
corner where there's rakes nothing but
rakes to step on because they were like
yeah release the tapes release the tape
you remember this these [__] idiots I
bet I could go to DC Dano's account
right now and just type in release the
tapes and there'll be all kinds of
tweets where he's asking for the speaker
of the house to release the tapes and if
he doesn't release the tapes then he's a
communist or some dumb [__] now
because speaker Johnson is trying to
make it to where they aren't rounding up
a bunch of his
constituents because he's releasing
these tapes DC Drano is saying that he's
[__] blurring the people's faces why
why why do they get the feeling they're
going to accidentally blur the faces of
undercover federal agents and
assets this is the narrative coming from
the right I want you guys to understand
this because this DC tape stuff is going
to keep being in the news and the reason
why it's going to keep being in the news
is
because they're gonna keep catching
these people okay they're going to keep
catching these people because these
tapes are being released some of the
faces of persons who uh
participate that's
right and what and what they're going to
say is is the reason why he's blurring
them is because now micro Johnson is
part of the deep State that's his claim
he's making here is that either he is
part of the deep State or the Deep state
has convinced him and got to him so
that's why he's blurring the faces of
undercover agents and
assets so micro Johnson has one more
strike against him with the extreme
right-wing Maga in this country listen
Mike Johnson is not going to survive
this speaker ship just like Kevin
McCarthy didn't survive the speakership
just mark it down you can write this
down to December 6th Wednesday at 11:18
p.m Eastern uh in 2023 Tony Michaels
said that micro Johnson will not survive
this speakership he will lose his seat
because he became
speaker that's what this guy will do he
will lose his [__] seat and the
reason why is because you can't please
these people because they paint
themselves into these fascist Corners
with all these rates out in front of
them because that's all they do is
lie like like my Johnson here is lying
when he's like oh well we have to blur
the faces of these people to protect him
from the
[Music]
doj he says he has to blur the faces to
protect him from the doj the doj has
these tapes folks they have the tapes
they just don't have enough [__]
agents and enough [__] assets to find
all these son of a [__] that's why
they don't mind that the house releases
these tapes so that people on the
internet can use their manpower to go
find these people on social
media it's not complicated but he's
lying he's lying what he's doing is he's
protecting people from being prosecuted
so that they can release the tapes and
pretend that they're doing this big
favor for America by releasing the tapes
without Prosecuting a bunch of his
constituents it's all another big
[__]
lie but I mean you shouldn't be you
shouldn't be surprised you should not be
surprised so DC Drano giving away the
the game there um basically saying that
they're gonna turn on Mike Johnson
because Mike Johnson can't keep the lies
together all right let me get to this
clip of Jasmine Crockett oh my God
I [__] love
her I like not only is she she got the
[__] attitude I mean look at this she
has got the [__] attitude through and
through
folks but she's beautiful and she's from
the great state of Texas here and it's
funny because yesterday this clip it
triggered a bunch of [__] MAA
snowflakes because she said the words
deplorable and states oh my God they got
so [__] triggered by words it is so
[__] it is so
hilarious this is why I say the left
needs to stop getting triggered by words
because when they get triggered by words
here it's [__] fantastic just watch
Jasmine cracket trigger these some
[__] when lawmakers like this are so
far out of touch with what women need we
see States pushing back at least states
that will allow you to push back I'm
from the state of Texas and of course
they don't want you to ever have an
opportunity to raise voice in the state
of Texas in fact Miss Perry I know your
organization the Heritage Foundation
loves Texas oh they love Texas they
always sending us some nonsense bills um
that somehow set this country on the
wrong trajectory they send them to Texas
they send them look look at look at look
at the faces in the
[Laughter]
background I knew I was gonna go on a
coughing fit with this I can't help it
she so [__] good look at them in the
background oh my God they're trying so
hard not to [__] crack up as she just
[__] wads Heritage Foundation up and
dunks them in the [__]
garbage oh my God look at their faces
let's back it up I want to watch it
again watch watch him try to keep a
straight face when she just [__] just
hammers the Heritage Foundation here
watch and of course they don't want you
to ever have an opportunity to raise
your voice in the state of Texas in fact
Miss Perry I know your organization the
Heritage Foundation loves Texas they
love Texas they always sending us some
nonsense bills um that somehow set this
country on the wrong trajectory they
send them to Texas they send them to
Florida every deplorable state that we
can think about they usually coming out
of y'all's think tank
but every deal State it's always coming
out of y'all s tank oh my God I am so
you know the one reason why I love
Jasmine Crockett so much she she is a a
congresswoman from the great state of
Texas but she is she is from St Louis
originally so she speaks my Missouri
language okay she speaks my Missouri
language she has that Country Grammar if
you know what I'm talking about from
Nelly she has that in her voice she has
it in her Cadence and her Tempo and her
her fuckum attitude is on high
100% And I'm totally in love with
Jasmine Crockett being in the United
States Congress keep going but
nevertheless when we talk about
protecting women what we've seen is say
in the state of Ohio was one of the most
recent States when their lawmakers
didn't have the courage to do what they
needed to do because of course we
believeing and because we believe in
Terry mandering in this point of order
that that horrible voice you hear is
Marjorie Taylor green I I move to strike
her I mov to strike her words deplorable
States that's not a point of order let
the gentle lady proceed the committee
will suspend whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa the committee will
suspend just hold
slow now this committee
yesterday they were they they were
[__] they were being
deplorable and they were really really
casting hate language towards trans
athletes now yesterday they had held a
conference in the house to talk about
trans women in women's sports
that's what they talked about now um
what a lot of people don't know about
this is that there's over 200,000
Collegiate athletes um out there
200,000 and there's less than 50 trans
athletes that compete and even less than
50 are trans women okay so this is
almost a non-issue now I actually
believe that there can be a debate on
this issue
I I I strongly believe that trans women
have the right to compete in women's
sports right I that's what that's my
personal opinion on the issue that's my
personal opinion on the issue but I
believe that this is an issue that can
be debated I think there is cause for
debate for this issue for people to feel
comfortable in this situation the
problem is you can't have a debate with
these [__] disingenuous pieces of
[__]
Republicans do not bring good faith to a
debate they don't they haven't for a
long time they have not brought good
faith let me show you about good faith
uh let me show you the the the what I'm
talking about as the uh the chairwoman
Lisa mlan says this [__] listen to this
[__] rant that Lisa mlan in this
hearing gave I said here and listen to
every every label
imaginable I I am here to protect women
girl oh listen that Lisa mlan is there
to protect
women even though Lisa mlan voted
against the violence against women act
she voted against fair these Republicans
vote against the the the violence
against women act they vote against fair
pay for women uh they vote they vote in
favor of criminalizing and banning
Women's Healthcare okay and access to
health here all right get the [__] out
of here with this [__] again they're
not good faith actors but I don't know
you let her yell and scream about how
she loves women and then her vote says
something different but let her tell her
[__] lies out loud
girls my God why do I have to apologize
for that we spent decades trying to
protect women get the [__] out of here
with this [__] you have spent Deb
decades and decades and decades trying
to make women second class citizens in
this [__]
country [__] I've watched
it I've been
listening you [__] piece of [__] now
again I actually think in this country
we can have a reasonable debate on trans
athletes in sports we can have a
reasonable debate my opinion is is that
it's a non-issue and the trans athletes
should compete in the sports that's my
opinion and I think a debate will make
sure that that happens a real debate but
you can't have a [__] debate with
these people that's the problem I would
love for us to have a reasonable
conversation about and to put this issue
to bed that would be [__]
fantastic to have a reasonable
conversation inside our political
Discord
to put this issue to
bed so that way people in society feel
comfortable with it
right everyone feels comfortable not
just the [__] straight people and the
non-lgbtq community and white people but
the lgbtq community minority groups
especially trans people in sports feel
comfortable okay because they're [__]
humans too
[__] they're [__] too they
have rights and Liberties just like you
do and if you start taking away their
rights and Liberties yours are at risk
too so I believe that that issue around
the trans and I actually believe that
that issue that debate of trans athletes
in sports will make sure this country
actually does the thing and undermine
the bigotry that happens towards trans
people that's what I actually believe I
believe that debate will make it easier
for Trans people not to be [__]
terrified of these [__]
fascist but when you try to have a
debate with someone who doesn't bring
good faith to the debate you can't have
a debate it's not a debate it's not a
[__] it's not a [__] it's not a
reasonable conversation when this person
says she's trying to protect [__]
women when she's been doing the exact
opposite with every single else every
single other issue with women all of
them [__] all of them just listen to
this [__] piece of trash and you know
what we won we won so I will not
apologize now or ever we won who the
[__] is we and what did you win do you
mean do you mean we the people won in
Ohio when they told the [__]
Republicans you can't [__] touch our
rights to healthcare you can't
criminalize our rights to to healthcare
when when the people of Virginia told
Glenn yunan [__] no we're not going to
give you the majority so you can [__]
ban women's and criminalize Women's
Health Care you dumb [__] you
mean that what is this wee [__] Lisa
mlan what is this we [__] you got a
[__] Mouse in your pocket huh you got
a [__] Mouse in your pocket CA we
ain't on the [__] same side
when you're talking about women's rights
and Women's Healthcare you were trying
to [__] get rid of it you were trying
to make women second class citizens so
if you mean that you want trans women to
be just as second class as the other
women you want to be second class maybe
that's what you're talking about but you
ain't winning that [__] argument are
you keep going you [__] lying piece
of [__] for trying to protect my
daughters and women in sports and that's
what this hearing was about protecting
women you know what I am a woman all
right all right now now protect women in
doctor's offices protect their privacy
in doctor now do that mlan now do that
you [__] trunt do that [__] talk
about and have a hearing about
protecting women's rights and privacy in
a [__] doctor's office talk about
protecting their rights to receiving
Health Care to save their [__] lives
you [__]
[__] [__] get the [__] out of here with
this [__] and you think we can have
reasonable conversations with these
people yeah [__] no you can't have
people because these people do not have
good faith
conversations it's always lies always
lies and fraud with these
[__] [__] half the time they
don't even know what the [__] they're
arguing when they're arguing let me show
you this case in Missouri this is
[__] wild [__] this is in my state of
Missouri uh let me let me find this [__]
[__]
clip there's a member of the Nazi party
in Missouri who has introduced a bill to
make it a Class A Class a felony for a
woman to have a procedure to remove an
ectopic
pregnancy I'm not [__] you I
wouldn't [__] you're my favorite turd
now this is the committee meeting where
they're questioning this [__] [__]
his name
[Music]
is the the the representative the the
the Nazi party representative in
Missouri who is who is head sponsor of
this bill his name is Brian shitz [__] I
I don't know I don't know what to tell
you it's Brian shits and he wants to
criminalize Women's Health
Care and two sessions ago he admitted
that the death penalty would be on the
table in cases of abortion that's right
he's a prolifer isn't he no he's a pro
bir he's a forced birther he's a forced
birther but listen to this [__] this guy
wrote this bill in
Missouri to make it a Class B and a
class a felony to have a medical
procedure to save your [__] life as a
woman you know what he doesn't even know
what a Class A and a class B felony is
no clue watch this [__] watch
E felony no I do not it's minimum E
felony no I do not it's minimum of 5
years in prison maximum of 15 okay do
you know the range of punishment for a
class a felony no I do not it's a
minimum of 10 years in prison to a
maximum of 30 years in prison or life so
you're talk so this guy writes a bill in
Missouri gonna gonna make a medical
procedure a [__]
crime Class A and Class B felonies and
this [__] didn't even have the
brain power to look up let a class a
felony and a class B felony punishments
were didn't even have the [__] smarts
to look it up first has no clue but keep
listening it gets worse talking severe
penalties here it's a very serious issue
when we're talking about what I would
consider the murder of an infant INF in
the womb and the possible harm and
possibly even causes of death if they're
using these drugs and and these in an
illegal manner it could actually kill
the woman and I
think oh but he's okay with the death
penalty to kill the woman who's already
dead he's these people are [__] dumb
you know what the crazy part is look at
this guy it's this guy right down here
that wrote this [__] bill this piece
of [__] Nazi trash piece of Na na y
[__]
trash this [__]
is this son of a [__] right
here will never ever
ever have to live in fear under the law
that he has
written never have to live under the
fear of this law because number one he's
an old wrinkly white ball sack and he's
a [__] man
fascist [__] piece of
[__] keep listening it gets worse I
think that penalty is uh probably not
even strict enough not even strict
enough go as far as offering the death
penalty as a solution we'll have to look
at that in other
legislation we have to look at that in
other leg show the P let me get this
straight listen to this if a woman has
an eptopic
pregnancy it can threaten in her life
it's one of the most dangerous as far as
as far as I know I'm a man so I don't
know a lot about that [__] but from what
I understand it's one of the most
dangerous pregnancies that a woman can
have is an eptopic pregnancy and if you
don't know what it is go look that [__]
up almost all women know what it is
every single one of them know what it is
because it's it's the biggest danger to
their lives during
pregnancy it's one of the most deadly
[__] pregnancies out there is an that
topic pregnancy
okay what he's
saying is he's going to
criminalize the procedure to save a
woman's [__] life from an an that
topic pregnancy is not viable it can
never be a
baby it is a pregnancy that stops in the
fallopian tube if I'm
correct and it doesn't get down into the
[__]
womb and it can kill the woman it can
kill them and it's a slow painful death
it ain't like she just [__] wakes up
one day and's dead before she hits the
ground not that kind of [__] not that
kind of
dead it's a slow miserable [__] death
and what this piece of [__] wants to do
is he wants to pass a law in Missouri to
make sure that a woman has to suffer
that cruel pain painful torturous death
because if she didn't and she got her
ectopic pegnancy removed which in in all
real
honesty is an easy procedure by today's
standards it's still dangerous but they
do it all the time these procedures that
they use the drugs that they use save
women's
lives so that they can be a mother so
that they can get pregnant I know people
who are my friends personally that had
to have an eptopic pregnancy removed and
then went on to become a mother and
without having that eptopic pregnancy
removed they would have never been able
to be pregnant and be a
mother
never they went and had the procedure so
they could create life you [__]
dummy but this guy wants to make sure
that it's not only a class B felony it's
a class a felony which is 30 years to
life but he also wants to look at other
legislation to see if there's the death
penalty he claims in his little diet
tribe that it's so important that he
protects the life of The Unborn Child
which in an eptopic pregnancy will never
be a child an eptopic pregnancy is not
viable it will never become a [__]
human it is a dead
pregnancy but what he wants to do is in
case the woman has a procedure to save
her life that he claims to care about he
wants to [__] kill
her he wants to [__] kill her
dead
I mean I don't know if he wants to use
the electric chair if he wants to use
death by hanging I'm not really sure
maybe he wants to use death by hanger I
don't
know but this is the [__] Republican
Nazi party folks they're electing these
pieces of [__]
trash and that [__] [__] mlan is
yelling and screaming on Capitol Hill
that that they're protecting women get
the [__] out of here with that
[__] you can go [__]
yourself you can go [__] yourself mlan
and this piece of [__] right
here Brian shetz if you want to know his
name here I'll give you his [__] name
he's a goddamn elected official maybe
you could look him up if you're in
Missouri and call his [__] office and
tell him how much of a piece of trash he
is and how [__] h you got to be nice
about it don't threaten him don't do
that don't be an
idiot you need to follow Laura here bur
Laura burkart here also uh she's a great
Mom's demand action activist in Missouri
she's out of St Louis but you gotta
follow her on Twitter as well please
follow her on Twitter but here's his
name Brian
shits it's spelled s TZ I say shits cuz
[__] just flies out of this idiot's
mouth this fascist piece of [__] and let
me tell you something and ain't just
this [__] in Missouri there's a
there's handfuls of these Republican
fascist nazi men in Missouri that want
to
criminalize women's [__] health care
that's right he's a [__] [__] eater
cavad says he's a [__] eater shat eater
but I say [__]
eater [__] [__] what a [__]
[__] so go follow Laura because she
stays on top of this the same that Jess
Piper stays on top of the Missour
Missouri legislator and even if you're
not in the state of Missouri look
they're going to copycat this
[__] if you don't think these Nazis all
around the country are GNA copycat this
[__] stupid [__] you're out of your
goddamn
mind fascists are not creative folks
that's all they do is
copy that's all they [__] do is
copy
so if mlan claims that she is for women
because it's a trans transgender Sports
issue well [__] me
running because they ain't [__]
supporting women they ain't protecting
women or their rights or their lives
they don't give too [__] shits about
women other than for them to be [__]
brood mares for them to be Earth and
vessels and by God if you can't be an
earth and vessel then we'll put you to
[__]
death they're a [__] death cult is
what the [__] these Nazis are and
they're Nazis folks you don't believe me
oh they think Trump's a Nazi too look at
this I'm going to show you proof here
here Sebastian Gorka our friend Seb I
love you Seb here's Seb Gorka talking to
Matt vinm moats but listen watch the
Chiron here because they're talking
about Trump being a Nazi right because
that's what this does Nazi [__] rolls
downhill right Nazi [__] rolls downhill
and it's rolling downhill from Trump all
the way to
these that's right dictator from day
one but watch this watch the Chiron down
here see if you can spot something and
so all they're saying is Donald Trump
Nazi Nazi Nazi fascism dictatorship it
looks like that is their their campaign
platform for uh yeah well I mean it's
not our C PL campaign campaign platform
it's Trump's campaign yeah he wants to
be dictator in day one it's his campaign
platform it's not ours we're not we're
not forcing him to say this [__] Seb you
dumb son of a [__] but look at the
Chiron here Trump is a
Nazi let me tell you something I've been
saying they were Nazis for three [__]
years three years I've been on the
internet calling these [__]
Nazis and just in the last few weeks has
MSNBC on their Flagship show Morning Joe
decided to start called Trump a
fascist okay
that's right my rhetoric my my yelling
and screaming and saying it out loud not
giving a [__] what someone thinks about
it has started to seep into the
narrative it started to seep into the
narrative and even Morning Joe is using
the fword
Fascism and it's because of people like
me who've been yelling and screaming
that they're n capop Nazis for three
goddamn years because I've seen the
writing on the wall for a long time but
the best part is is that on sebgorka
show The Narrative is working because
they have to print the words on the
Chiron Trump is a
Nazi literally they have to spell it out
our messaging is working
folks our messaging is
working when Seb Gorka has to have on
his show the words Trump is a Nazi our
narrative is leaking even into their
media they can't help it anymore they're
on the defense we're on
offense we got to stay on [__]
offense trust me I know how to have some
[__] political
offense those guys at at at [__] uh
pod Saves America David Pacman uh uh NPR
some of these other [__] chuckleheads
they're all on defense folks every
[__] one of them is on defense just
go listen to them there's very few
leftwing commentators that are on
offense very few of them I'm always on
offense
always I want them to have to defend
their [__]
positions and this is a good example of
how we stay on offense and why offense
is so important because they start
printing [__] on their [__] chirons
they start putting text on their chirons
Trump is a Nazi but listen to this
little stupid crybaby diet tribe
2024 I think it's even worse I think
that they are green lighting
assassination yeah people talk about
Trump as hit ah this is more [__]
projection they're G they're
greenlighting assassination get the [__]
out of here everyone's calling for him
to be jailed you dumb son of a [__]
they're calling for him to be jail the
only people that are sending out death
threats are [__]
MAA that's the only people being
arrested for death threats like the guy
in Utah what was that stupid [__] name
if the FBI showed up at his house
because he was threatening to shoot Joe
Biden with a high power rifle
assassinate him at like a sniper style
so they went to his house and he ended
up [__] having a shootout with the
goddamn with the goddamn FBI and they
had to [__] shoot him dead that guy
huh okay Raider Nation here says Pac-Man
rocks are you talking about David Pacman
or the game
Pacman because I I gotta H I gotta tell
you David Pacman does is not good at
commentary he's not good he used to be
the standard of commentary he's not
anymore he's not I mean he's got you
know he's got syndication and you know
doesn't curse so he gets to be on a lot
of radio stations but he's no Trends
Setter Raider Nation and and and you
might like David Pacman you may go
listen to him fine whatever I I don't
care I can't tell you not to listen to
David Pacman but David Pacman is
horrible A Commentary he's horrible at
it most most of these [__] are
horrible at it they have to be scripted
they have to write it out they have to
be well produced to produce commentary
they have to really sit down and write
out an argument to make an argument
about
democracy it's pathetic really if you
want to know the honest truth that you
can't just make a simple argument about
democracy and you can't do it off the
cuff I mean maybe I'm off my rocker here
but I I I follow David I've watched
David's clips and his
[__] I I'm hoping that's the backman new
me rocks and Raider Nation there's no no
offense I I hope you keep listening to
me and I hope you keep going and listen
to Pacman because I would get the same
[__] when I would knock tyt a year ago a
year ago or a year and a half ago I
started saying tyt was [__] because it
it is [__] tyt is garbage it's [__]
trash and a lot of the audience is like
no you're wrong you're wrong you're
wrong and then they went and listened to
it after I said what I said about them
and they're like yeah maybe maybe you're
right maybe you're right listen David
could be really good at commentary again
if he wanted to be he could be really
good at it if he wanted to be I don't
know I maybe he does want to be I'd love
to have a conversation with David about
it in private or in public I would do it
in private or in public I would have a
conversation with him I've had a
conversations with a lot of American
commentators a lot of commentators that
you guys
know in private and in public for that
matter about this very [__] issue and
I'm telling you I'm telling you right
now that the leftwing and the left and
liberals in general
have needed someone like me for a long
time because there isn't someone like me
out there besides me and I hope that
they copycat me I mean I've already seen
people try to copycat me trying to do
what I do here on this show because a
lot of the left didn't do [__] live most
of the left produces their
show and then [__] post the [__]
they're like oh let's make a YouTube
video we'll post it so we get a lot of
views they're not willing to do a
[__] two-hour
show David does a radio show but he's
horrible at
it it's boring it's
dry he he he he it takes forever to talk
about and then the other thing too is he
really he really doesn't
um oh boy he doesn't punch as hard as he
should and he really doesn't defend
democracy like he should the other thing
that David does that I don't do is I
don't capitulate to the media's
narrative I mean during 2022 when there
was a Red Wave coming David Pacman if
you go listen to his commentary believe
the media's [__] when he would say
that there was a Red Wave coming you can
go listen to David in September of
2022 and he believed the media's
[__] about a red wave Tony Michaels
did not believe that
[__] I did not believe that
nonsense [__] no uh Hal Sparks is also
one that did not believe that
nonsense how does this show differently
though how doesn't do a show like it's
it's different how how definitely
punches at these people really hard I'll
give you that how punches and I've had
how on the show how's a friend of of
mine I've talked to Hal in private and
I've talked to him in
public and Hal does a great job with his
show it's just different than what mine
is it's
different uh Richard o Jetta major does
a show and it's different than mine he
punches pretty hard but it's just
different it's got a different
tone so you know say what you want I
hope I hope there's a lot of CopyCat out
there I hope more people copy me I've
been seeing that I've been seeing that a
lot people copying me or try to copy me
when I do on this show I've been seeing
it and I'm glad I'm happy for it I hope
more and more people copy me that's what
I want that's what I want I want people
to copy Andrea says how and Tony are
both live so they'll always have my
attention and heart thank you Andrea
thank you Andrea H how does a great show
and me and Hal like we we agree on
almost all the [__] and the reason why
is because me and Hal are
liberals capital L liberals Hal is a
liberal and he's not he's not scared to
say that he's he doesn't hide it right
and I I believe Hal has that new that
new style that new brand of liberalism
that is coming that that we see in
moscowitz that we see in Crockett that
we see in
Federman that we these people who are
willing to [__] stand up and pound
their fist and say [__] you you're a
dummy and here's why you're a dummy
so um baw says all great so is Pacman
listen I I'm not saying you shouldn't
listen to
him I'm not saying you shouldn't listen
to him I'm not saying that I'm saying
when you listen to him you should really
listen you should really
listen that's all I'm saying and use use
your your critical thinking and logic
when you're listening to what they're
saying that's all I'm saying just keep
your ears open keep it
open did did someone say Glen
too ah I see you're trying to [__]
bait me someone's trying to bait me in
getting on Glen
to I see what you're doing you're
throwing the bait out there no I mean I
like Glenn I like Glenn but the 14th
Amendment stuff is stupid it's really
stupid now Marcus said he quit he quit
tyt cold turkey how'd that go did you
get the
shakes
H yeah you need to quit tyt I mean you
can go you can go um listen to Pacman um
go listen to some of these others that I
knock but definitely don't listen to tyt
that shit's garbage I mean there's like
the rebel
HQ on they got the rebel HQ YouTube
channel a lot of those most people are
kind of independent and they do
independent videos so they're pretty
good because they're not under The
Narrative of tyt and [__] uh Jank
younger uh so you know there's a lot of
those Independence and uh Ben Glee I've
had Ben Glee on the show and Ben Glee
has been really pushing back on Jen
gunger if you watched any of the stuff
on tyt yeah I keep up with it I gotta
make sure that what I'm saying is still
true I watch David Pacman Clips too I
watch David's clips
to make sure I keep up with his boring
ass so I know he's still boring and I
know what I'm saying about him is still
true that he's still horrible at
commentary and he is I mean you know you
can hate me and love me whatever you
know but I just tell the
truth oh boy
oh boy lucky who we have here lucky who
we have here the guy with the last name
send
hey are you gonna be a dictator on your
show today are you I'm gonna I'm from
day one day one
okay are you gonna be a dictator today
tell us what you're gonna talk about
Gabe Sanchez while I put your link up uh
I got an update on my car situation oh
really yeah it's not
good we'll talk about that we're going
to of course talk about the dictator
we're going to talk about Kevin McCarthy
the Cowardly Lion who said he would
never quit I'm not
quitting oh I knew he was quit and then
of course we're going to cover uh George
Santos and Mike Johnson it's gonna be a
[__] a circus micro
Johnson that's that's what they call him
the speaker the wiener of the house the
guy the guy with such a small member of
Congress that he will blur out the
private
information so that people people are
safe oh really yeah so he has a small
member is what you're saying I actually
I saw he a yes he has a small member of
Congress well uh you know what else I
speaking of small members of Congress I
heard the Elf on the Shelf Patrick
McKenry is not going to seek reelection
either so he's out too so there's gonna
be there's gonna be taller people in
Congress possibly I mean the average the
average will go up you know so have you
got any great new news on your buddy GE
Santos who is a former member of
Congress you got any news on that that
you're going to cover today I know that
you know he's become a cam girl I mean a
cameo girl oh oh okay okay uh I mean he
loves only fans apparently I hear that
so maybe here's the thing like anyone
out there who's like I'm gonna buy look
I'm just gonna say this right now if
you're out there and you're saying like
I'm gonna buy a cameo as a joke don't do
it don't do it I don't know I thought
the fedman one was pretty good okay that
one when you're trolling like that for
sure
however now I think I got a notification
because I was I'm I'm on Cameo as well
and I I just like uh I reactivated my
profile to like go in and see his
account and within six hours I got a
message from someone asking if they
could take photos of my feet which I was
like I don't know how that works I would
do they had but here's the thing they
had to pay to message me so that's jokes
on them um I would totally I would
totally if someone wanted a picture of
my [__] yeah I'll send you a picture of
my feet do whatever you want [__]
weiro message that that I got [__] [__]
you pay me let me let me just read you
this message real quick let me go into
Cameo uh boom okay inbox somebody I
won't say their name they said Gabe you
rock well thanks let me know if you want
me sorry let me know if you want to make
money to make videos of your Footwear
and feet it'd be super easy and it'd
mean a lot from you let me know because
they'd be super dope I'd pay on venmo or
PayPal if preferred please make DMS
free it cost like two bucks I didn't
even know there was a setting but it
cost $2 a DM so you it kind of brings
hearkens me back to that uh great
picture that we had of Tony Tony sucks
Gabe walks it feels like those were your
shoes and that's what they want is they
want a video of you putting on those
shoes that's maybe maybe I should get
maybe I should make this guy my my sugar
daddy yeah your feet daddy your foot
dadd and be like look I need a new car
so you know if you want to buy me a new
car that's it that's it new Wheels Gabe
Sanchez needs new wheels go to Cameo and
buy feet photos and videos from go do
your show go do go do your show go do
your show everyone stick around here on
YouTube stick around on Twitch what was
that live with Gabe Sanchez coming up
right after this show thanks for joining
me today I had so much fun with you guys
as always make sure that you guys go to
the Tony michaels.com find your favorite
way to support the show but as I said
earlier there is a promo code 10% off
your entire order in the tattoo merch
store go to the tattoo merch collection
on the Tony michaels.com use the promo
code holiday 10 that's holiday10 holiday
all caps one zero holiday we'll have a a
coupon day it is a coupon it's coupon
day until Sunday for 10% off your entire
tattoo merch order use the promo code
holiday 10 that's holiday 10 I
appreciate every single one of you same
time same place stick around for Gabe
Sanchez stick around don't go anywhere
on YouTube or twitch you'll go directly
over there surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow Tony
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking